what i'm gonna do in this review is take
a look at the m1 macbook air with my
thoughts on how it holds up compared to
the current m1 pro macbooks as well as
its eventual m2 chip replacement the m1
air is still an absolutely incredible
value even after a full year and i would
fully recommend this macbook air over
any other windows laptop in its price
range the next contender apple's most
recent 14 inch m1 pro macbook pro if you
can't take advantage of those extra
features and the extra performance on a
daily or at least a weekly basis then
spending the extra cash simply is not
going to be worth it the last contender
the upcoming redesigned m2 macbook air
if you can stretch your budget all the
way up to around 1200 then the new m2
air is gonna be totally worth spending
the extra cash but if you're limited to
under a thousand dollars and you don't
really want to wait potentially up to a
full year then the current m1 macbook
air is still hands down the best laptop
you can buy right now